all right what's going on guys this is
Robin and before we start this video I
have been invited to the press junket
for the bloodshot film on Friday I was
invited yesterday so it's a really tight
turn around and when I did the press
junket for spider-man far from home a
lot of you guys asked were there
questions you could ask or a lot of guys
suggested that like next time you know
hit us up in like we can ask her
questions because like that I was like
that's actually a pretty cool idea it's
a really good way to get you guys
involved right to get you guys feeling
like you're more incorporated with
regards to these the you know the
channel and and me and the press junkets
that I get to do and things like that
so here's what I want you guys to do
right the the press junket is of course
for Vin Diesel the director and most of
the supporting cast in the description
you'll find those individuals and I'm
actually going to be interviewing as
part of the press junket what I want you
to do is I want you to go into the
comments section and I want you to post
your questions but I want you to say
then be salt : your question right so
like the individuals that I have listed
those individuals you know their names
call in question I want you to follow
that format if you do not follow that
format I'm not going to pay any
attention to your question I'm gonna
ignore your question entirely because I
don't have enough time to kind of filter
through what it is you mean to say and
all that kind of stuff because this is
in a couple days right so I've got to be
fast about all this kind of stuff from
there I'll pick the questions that I
think are the most interesting using my
own judgement and then I'll send those
off to my contact and so need to make
sure that the questions are copacetic if
not then you know we can kind of figure
it out from there and I can go back and
pick some different questions um but
then yeah so assuming that then it all
works out then who knows you might get
your question asked to then diesel then
diesel might answer your question for
you so we'll see once we'll see what's
up but unless you guys post those down
in the comments and let's start the
video
okay so a lot of you guys really seemed
to enjoy the video that we did on the
origin of the Transformers and Cybertron
and so I figured we would cover more
transformer stuff since you guys have
really been asking for it right which is
nice I kind of like taking a reprieve
from Marvel in DC I mean we still cover
them but it's nice to bring in something
else kind of a breath of fresh air more
or less you know I don't want to be
pigeonholed as a guy that only ever
covers Marvel in DC and nothing else
right so because of that I want to cover
the origin of Optimus Prime and Megatron
now here's the funny thing about this is
going over these different stories and
so on and so forth but there are
different origins out there because like
the TV show is order the the various TV
shows it really kind of gets into their
own universes unless is specified that
one continues out to the other the
movies are their own universes the
comics of their own individual universes
again unless something takes place in
one series that ties it into another
they're usually kind of considered to be
their own thing right and stuff the cool
thing about this is that when it comes
to transformers prama when it comes to
Optimus Prime and Megatron this one I
think it's the most consolidated and
reasonable origin and the reason why is
because it really kind of brings them
together right really kind of says that
like you know one hand washes the other
so to speak and so far that and what you
had in the history of Cybertron was what
was called the Golden Age and the Golden
Age is one of these these instances were
like nobody was fighting over resources
everybody on Cybertron lived in peace
that kind of a thing so you know not
really hippie dippie or anything like
that but just a place where like things
didn't suck was basically basically the
Golden Age of Cybertron but as time
began to progress you ran into the same
thing you always run into whenever you
have multiple groups who are living in
the same location you end up having the
creation of social classes and so what
you got was kind of a reflection of the
real world you know the world in which
we live where you basically had
differing hierarchies of social classes
essentially the the kind of George
Orwell philosophy that everybody is
equal but some are more equal than
others if you guys understand where I'm
where I'm kind of going with that
basically you had like these
all-powerful ruling classes and then you
have the guys all the way down at the
very very bottom and for the most part
there was a lot of anger that was
brewing at the time right there was a
lot of resentment a lot of
dissatisfaction that was going on among
the masses in on the on on the planet
Cybertron and so what you ended up
getting is you had Orion Pax and then
you had megatronus and megatronus was
essentially a gladiator and using the
kind of fame that he was able to draw by
the various you know
various battles that he won or
gladiatorial games that he won he
started to build a kind of following and
using that he began to sort of you know
espouse this ideology that like things
need to change right we have to make
things better for people and so the
result was that in in deriving a kind of
following he in turn had his own
audience base at the same time what you
had was Orion package but Orion Pax
didn't really have a following in the
traditional sense he kind of did but not
in the same way that megatronus did the
way that Orion Pax worked out is he was
really more of a clerk working in the
Hall of Records and looking into the
past of the Golden Age of Cybertron when
everything was great for everyone he
looked a sort of return back to that age
but he didn't really see it by means of
conquest and conquering that's not
really what he was looking for instead
he had more of a philosophical hint and
saying like we need to return to this
era of peace without any bloodshed if at
all possible
now some folks got to be killed you
can't make an omelet without breaking a
few eggs but like we're not gonna kill
everybody right and so as a result of
this we're the two of them really seem
to have the same ideologies that when
megatronus had essentially left the
Claddagh tutorial games and then a
Dodger the name of Megatron really kind
of shortening his name down when he
approached the High Council this is when
you really learned what he was about and
what you ended up finding out here is
that what he wanted to do was
essentially disband and eliminate the
High Council and then put himself in
place as essentially a dictator of
Cybertron now the biggest problem with
this and in reality if you had something
like an enlightened monarch it wouldn't
be the worst thing right because what
you would have is is a kind of monarchy
class where hopefully you know
generation after generation people would
operate in what's best for the overall
you know society in this instance is an
entire planetary society and so as a
result of that when he essentially
wanted to espouse the idea of becoming a
dictator the biggest issue you run into
there is essentially Megatron basically
being corrupted by his own power which
was really seem to be the case given the
kind of kind of speech he was making
insofar as you know if people have to
die and that's okay right like it
doesn't matter you know they're you know
there's it's just the way that it's just
things go but it's also one of the only
individuals who would be welcome on
Cybertron who would be considered part
of the accepted class as I see it or
individuals who are deemed accepted by
me right so people who agree with me
right that's really kind of the
philosophy that he was espousing and how
it was interpreted on the other hand in
the equation when though the High
Council had listened to the arguments of
Orion Pax what they saw was essentially
somebody who seemed to model the ideals
of the original primes
of Primus which is to say people who
fought on the side of justice people who
fought on the side of equality for all
individuals on Cybertron and so the
result of this is that Oh Ryan Pax was
was really sort of favored by the High
Council and the High Council in turn
rejected the arguments of Megatron and
so what it did is that led to Megatron
turning his back on the High Council and
Orion Pax and then in turn using his
followers which he called the
Decepticons to wage war against pretty
much anybody who was not considered to
be someone who followed in the
ideologies of Megatron himself and so
during this time because the fact of the
war of of Megatron had essentially you
know more or less poise in the core of
Cybertron itself meaning it was
literally killing Primus what Orion Pax
had done was travelled to the core of
Cybertron itself now Megatron was on the
hunt for the matrix of leadership but
the matrix of leadership you know I
guess really for anybody who follows the
traditional ideologies of Cybertron and
even those who sort of idolized the
Golden Age really saw it as more of a
philosophical slash religious relic it
wasn't really just an absolute source of
power they could use for their own ends
if you possess the matrix of leadership
its stood for something
the Decepticons themselves would it
looked more to the matrix of leadership
for the power it possessed right
Megatron could use that to achieve his
own ends and so you know as a result it
was really kind of hunting for the same
artifact but for two different reasons
and this is really one of the more
important things here because when Orion
Pax found the matrix of leadership when
he found Primus
Primus almost kind of took this approach
those you guys coming from Marvel Comics
it was very similar to like the Panther
God bats from the Black Panther comics
right like when a person is trying to
become the new Black Panther you have to
go through a whole bunch of tests but
the final test you go through is
basically presenting yourself in your
most humble form to the Panther God and
if the Panther God rejects you it would
probably kill you right but at the very
least you would not become Black Panther
if the Panther God looks at you and
accepts you then you would become the
new Black Panther and that's more or
less what Primus did that when Primus
looked upon a lion pax and realized that
he was there for the purpose of not only
helping farmers but trying to help
Cybertron itself Pradas looked upon him
favorably and granted him the mat the
matrix of leadership now what this looks
like it indicates is that if Megatron
had shown up here that Megatron would
not have received it the promise would
have just let you know things were just
played out however they played out
probably to the doom of all the
Transformers and that really would have
been
the alternative is that you know
Megatron and his forces would have
stormed the core they would have stormed
Primus and then taken the matrix of
leadership but regardless of how it
possibly could have played out what a
riot pax was given the matrix of
leadership he became Optimus Prime and
then essentially he and the Autobots had
been warring against the Decepticons and
Megatron ever since right so it's a cool
origin right and I think it's one of the
most cohesive and I think it's one of
the most well put together when it comes
to these stories of the of the
Transformers but again this is one of
multiple origins that are out there
right so to me I think it's the most
recent one as far as I'm aware again I
just watch the series on Netflix right I
just watch you know I kind of looked at
it here and there and then watch the the
very end of the series where you
basically get kind of how this all sort
of came together um but I I've you know
I've done it no I am I was interested in
it it may be that with the the recent
relaunch of transformers from IDW that
they may go back and change the order or
give us a new origin and if they do of
course I'll cover that but at the moment
I'm not aware of their being although it
may be that I've just missed it you were
like 20-something issues in so maybe
that I just missed it for some reason or
another but regardless let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section if you are new here to come as
explained to make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the rob4 if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace I want to say thank you to
all of the new patrons who have joined
patreon.com slash comics explained I
want to give a shout out to Henry young
- Elias G David J s Jacob H Ben John H
Jason see Austin s Austin H James O
kristymatt in Jeff are Joey M Steven Z
sloth-like lu-david C John H lean and
mean that guy asked questions all the
time Adam Kage enosis 9:16 i want to say
thank you to all of you all this list is
growing all the time thank you joining
the patreon
[Music]